foreign
ER strikes and these actor strikes and
there's people who are strike busting
can you believe it can you believe
they're strike busting can you believe
that they're strike busting
this is I you know I gotta say this is
hilarious because yeah on the one hand
you have all the right Wingers dunking
on them so like nobody watches you
nobody cares and then you have the
lefties that watch them that are like
you're strike busting like they made
nobody happy with this announcement
Jimmy Kimmel tweeted out for the
remainder of the strike uh Stephen
Colbert Jimmy Fallon Seth Meyers John
Oliver and I joining forces for a new
podcast called Strike Force Five hear
the first episode tomorrow 8 30 all
proceeds uh thanks to uh Casa Amigos and
uh which is a booze company which is
tequila that's Run by George Clooney and
somebody else and mint mobile so they're
running ads on this just so you know uh
we'll go to support our support are out
of work staffs listen now so the money's
not gonna is gonna the money's gonna go
to
the staff of their shows not like other
people like the staff of their specific
shows because instead of doing like and
by the way what Conan did and I'll say
what you want about Coney are really gay
there towards the end but what Conan did
during the strike and I'll never forget
this was
he didn't go beg for money this and that
he paid his entire staff out of his own
pocket his pocket not the company out of
his own pocket while they were off he
paid him myself he goes I'll pay you
guys it's fine I'll pay you guys and he
bought a lot of love because he did that
you know
um didn't bother Tonight Show though no
no one more time Jimmy yeah hi I'm Jimmy
Fallon I'm Stephen Colbert I'm Jimmy
Kimmel I thought when you said Jimmy you
meant me Jimmy but you meant Jimmy oh my
God these people have no idea what to do
in our world and it's gonna be so good
to watch this is gonna this is gonna
hopefully yield some great stuff these
people have no
you're in the wrong place now you're in
our world now guys oh I hate oh oh this
is gonna be good this is gonna be good
one more time Jimmy
hi I'm Jimmy Fallon I'm Stephen Colbert
I'm Jimmy Kimmel I thought when you said
Jimmy you meant me Jimmy but you meant
Jimmy Jimmy I always mean you but when
you always be at Myers who do you oh my
God they can't even not talk over each
other it's the five of us together for
uh maybe an hour a day Strike Force Five
is the name of our podcast subscribe to
it now
Spotify or wherever else you get oh my
God
holy [__] they don't even want to be
there bro
you can tell that like they don't want
to be there that this was something
somebody else concocted to make money
and they're like I guess wow they're not
gonna survive in this world you can't
survive in this world you don't know
what to do here
the you know what it is the powers that
be we're not happy that their late night
message wasn't getting out that's a good
point because now because of the strike
they can't use them as the [__]
propaganda machine like they did as much
you know because oh God you're right and
by the way and I agree they didn't get
any ratings I'm not arguing they got
ratings they didn't get any ratings but
it wasn't about the ratings it was about
the little clips that they could post on
Twitter you know of the shows that's
what it is
that's exactly what it is and I'll tell
you what they're gonna [__] form
together like a Voltron robot and
they're still not going to beat my good
friend gutsy's numbers you know man tell
guts used to come on the show Marsh yeah
you know gutsy won't even retweet me
doesn't even talk to me anymore he
talked to you once
follows me on Twitter though yeah I know
I know I know I'm still trying to work
it out with bongino about the Bongos
Awards so we'll see yeah I know that's
it he's that bongino is uh his voice is
gutsy yeah follows him but he doesn't
interact with them in any meaning no no
no no no no no no are you kidding me why
would he ever interact with me no no no
I know we're both both terrible people
hey there's the first step I'm never I'm
never gonna get the smell cat Tim's hair
what's wrong with you
I am
I am but it's gonna be what she's at a
restaurant
let's get a good whiff okay their first
episode which I have it here there's no
video by the way why would but guys
so you're doing a podcast right
okay you and and the most famous part
about you is that people know who you
are by your face and you guys decided to
do an audio only podcast
really Seth Meyers is starting to look
like uh Tony Hawk so that's true what
would happen if five of America's top 11
most beloved talk show hosts all talked
on top of each other for an hour
we're about to find out on the first
ever edition of Strike Force Five wow
your mic sounds like [__] too like they
didn't even mix anything let's meet the
strike force starting with the former
host of The Late Show at Stephen Colbert
from his headquarters in South Carolina
Stephen Colbert hello Jimmy it's an
honor to be here this is where we should
all applaud each other it is an honor to
be with you here Stephen next from his
home studio in Long Island where he
stays up late every night recording
himself singing along with the Bee Gees
karaoke the former host of The Tonight
Show Jimmy Fallon hello Jimmy Fallon
former house well they're saying former
to all of them because they're on strike
thank you so happy to be here this is
exciting uh good good morning mention to
the listeners for the purposes of this
podcast Jimmy will be known as Tammy
from here on and then give me the
upstairs TV neighbor fans of this show
man their jokes are really funny huh
I missed the good old days when late
night hosts were funny and hated each
other you know why they have Kimmel
running at first because Kim was the
only one that ever did Regular radio out
of the group
oh God that's right Kim was the only one
who ever did Regular radio beat boys
unemployment Zone Seth Meyers Seth it's
just so exciting to be talking before 12
37 at night say hello to the lady said
tell us what color are your eyes I I
looked at pictures of you a lot of the
night last night I can't figure it out
I've been told ocean blue Jimmy and for
those who will criticize us who say we
don't need a show hosted by a group of
four middle-aged straight white how did
he get so bad and [__] Adam Carolla
got so good I don't because well I don't
know one of them sold their soul we
bring you a fifth middle-aged straight
white man but this one is from England
none of yours right entirely different
country oh he's from England so there's
going to be a delay on his Zoom he is
the currently forced majority former
host of Last Week Tonight John Oliver
hello John hello Kimmel first I'd say
Saturday is a Gatorade blue but you know
reasonable people can disagree also I
cannot believe you're the only one who
gets to have a soundboard I didn't know
we were doing soundboards that changes
everything as we mentioned we we are the
striker this is edited this is heavily
edited yeah listen
like it's one thing that like expect a
little delay between them talking but
there's there's not even a natural delay
in in them talking like a conversational
conversational way yeah it cuts right
like some dude Jimmy had some intern cut
out a lot of like dead air and probably
like shitty jokes okay let's skip to the
middle tour maybe they're probably
gelling and riffing is it yeah yeah
Managua uh for the holidays so he was
like Harry pottering and my family was
the Weasleys and oh good guys you want
to hear about rich people talk about
their Rich families are you excited
isn't a podcast breaking the strike it's
great you bring that up
it is and they're getting beat up for it
they're getting beat up because they're
breaking the strike Anastasio Samosa and
then whatever the last year he went back
after they graduated he left his clothes
at my grandparents house oh boy and
Jimmy is trying to flex some muscle he
hasn't used in a while which is His
Radio muscle and you see it because I
can see what he's doing you could tell
Jimmy is the one that used to do radio
because he's trying to but he's still
but the problem is
it's evolved since last time he did it
and it's not like he was doing a wacky
morning Zoo oh boy oh it's wild wild
so I have Anastasio samosa's pants
wow yeah dude I'm look I'm looking at
Stephen like I've never really gave a
[__] about Stephen Colbert before other
than he just sucks um
but the more you read about this guy
because it's off the more Sinister it is
oh yeah
like his early life and everything and
his relatives he's a Catholic minister
my mom drinks her coffee out of
Ferdinand marcos's skull my mom gave
dude
nobody's laughing everyone's trying to
get this [__] in and like the the
editing the editing is it sounds like
those prep Burger interviews every one
of these people hates doing this job
once well yeah they all hate it but dude
listen very carefully When anybody but
Jimmy talks and then Jimmy talks it
sounds exactly like those so we got
Taylor Swift here Taylor tell me about
the new album man it's just yeah exactly
prep a prepper a prep Burger interview
yeah it's terrible fine but that's
pretty that's 75.
laughs
was that a bad year for [__] well I
thought maybe when he was up and you
know he tried out for the Yankees he
can't make hand job jokes that's that's
you know why it's heavily heavily edited
too it's heavily edited because of that
because it's bad because they might
accidentally like Jimmy Kimmel might
have funny they might accidentally right
exactly they might walk in all the
[__] joke in their head but they were
funny they might accidentally be funny
and it'll be too edgy and they have to
cut it you you homos can't survive in
our world you cannot survive in this
world I get it you have all the viewers
you got all the money and the Jets and
all the [__] [__] but you you can
you cannot live with us okay and Roy
Royce are you there
I'm sorry were you talking to meemer or
the other Royce
the fox nine because he's here Royston
five Nine's also on the show for some
reason that's right guys voice coming in
from Davenport okay Prince Royce lives
in Davenport
it's like me doing this is so gay that's
not fair merch we're trying not to be
funny and we're still funnier than them
it's really not and we're not trying you
guys suck you you know what
you guys should get those Riders back
it has to be a part of another talk show
before you were doing this particular
show because I was interviewed and I
think I was kind of offered the job uh
to be the announcer on the magic hour
I was offered the job to be the
announcer on the magic hour I know
another person Kim sharp remember Jim
Sharp for wait wait a minute Jim Sharp
was at Comedy Central right but he went
and produced The Magic so they're gonna
talk hold on guys guys are you ready to
talk about inside baseball at Comedy
Central are you excited
you guys [__] suck
hey how come all of your stories about
Comedy Central never take place on a
Saturday
oh man that's mean I've been offer would
be the job as the announcer on the magic
dude listen I I can I read this I know
this is like I mean it's on topic but
it's like well they're talking about the
Colgate they're talking about the
Colgate comedy I remember you want to
hear more about it
all buffano
Roy dunk you have the kink in the alto
I have to read this sorry go ahead
Stephen Colbert's early life this is so
just psychotic okay
originally his surname was pronounced
Colbert in English Stephen Colbert
Colbert's Father James wanted to
pronounce the name Colbert but
maintained The Colbert pronunciation out
of respect for his own father he offered
his children the option to pronounce the
name whichever the way they performed
what Stephen started using Colbert later
in life when he transferred to
Northwestern University taking advantage
of the opportunity to reinvent himself
in a new place where no one knew him
this is such an erotic crazy he was born
to be a [__] NWO propagandist he just
wants to be like you know what I mean oh
my God somebody Forrest Mommy goes how
is Colbert funny on Strangers With Candy
then to this because he had writers
he had funny writers
but listen to this
so the dad
their name is Colbert the dad wanted to
pronounce it Colbert but didn't because
he respected his dad but then planted it
in all his kids had that they could
choose how to pronounce their last name
like what is going on that's insane
right
how weird and that's another story that
he made up
there are pathological Liars the truth
of the matter is he didn't okay but fine
pathological but this the most telling
part is Steven started using a different
pronunciation later taking advantage of
an opportunity to reinvent himself by
pronouncing his name slightly
differently that's insane that's insane
I'm Reinventing myself I'm Roy slopes
now
but like that's you know everybody
already knows you doesn't matter
Reinventing myself going to Northwestern
just change you don't have to be Lopes
just just change the spelling like uh
Lisa Left Eye Lopez oh with an S and
then just still pronounce it Lopez yeah
I like that uh it's pronounced with an s
um Lopes they're really funny is the
point um
I was interviewed by Lon Rosen whose
Magic's um manager this does sound like
the pulp the Colgate Comedy Hour talking
this all inside baseball [__] nobody
cares about he is dude
that was a big meeting that that
everybody was there but Jim was the guy
who called me sorry Fallon go ahead give
me what lime rosen's real
yet did you get offered that same job no
no my uh my friend did he was this gonna
be the sidekick and then got really
close and they got replaced I think by
Craig Shoemaker maybe right Shoemaker
Shoemaker got the gig okay cool I know
you guys all know these people oh my God
holy [__] this is [__] crazy it this
so their first episode it immediately
became talking about the craft and
inside baseball they cannot help
themselves merge they cannot these
people cannot help themselves they can't
they can't merge when there's no Riders
and there's a strike it's not about them
for five seconds and they can't have
that they cannot have that
what is funniest of course of all of us
would be if John Oliver was the
announcer on the magic hour it's not too
late
I love the theme song Magic I used to
watch that all the time is it Sheila E
was the musical director yes she was I
was so I I got I remember back in like
96 it was me and Julia Sweeney right we
were doing the brown links and it was
like what are you doing nobody cares
this is [__] terrible so smug and
shitty you got they don't they don't
want to be relatable at all exactly they
don't know how to be people they don't
know how to it's like with late stage
Stern when Stern stop being like you
know everyday [__] scummy Jew guy
yeah I was with uh Beth we were in the
Hamptons and uh we were doing uh you
know something for the North Shore
Animal League yeah I I remember one time
tuning in to stern it not because I
listened to know but because I think Ona
were like on vacation or something for
real time let me see if this I was the
same right like let me see what's turns
out too oh and A's a replay I guess Ant
song over yeah
so I would listen to him and I remember
tuning in and it was it was an entire
segment of him saying yeah I was up in
the Hamptons and I love the place that
we stayed at because my personal chef
knows exactly how to make my eggs
because I like my eggs really dry and I
was like
what am I listening to this Howard Stern
said what happens what the [__]
happening here it's more relatable if
like when people go like ah you know as
a you know so my uh you know whatever
vacation that's when I [__] I had to
fix the Shelf like when it's like a
story about fixing a shelf that's more
relatable yeah you did something I
couldn't relate to this but they're
literally yeah my personal chef dude it
was super weird and I'm like who are you
talking to most of your listeners are
Truckers
went to this meeting uh I think I'm
literally like I'm out for pilot season
and I get nothing that's so true though
now all I can think of is a trucker is
you're like yeah my personal chef makes
my eggs dry like I like and it's like oh
yeah I ate a tuna sandwich and a loves
and the shower was busted it's at the
showers busted so I had to go to the
Flying J yeah I had a brisket sandwich
in the parking lot of a Bucky's while I
fueled up yeah so yeah and I'm sure your
private Chef was great so it was just
like and people complain about us
bitching about people being poor
um
bro it makes me laugh anytime
like somebody gets mad like that person
that tweeted you the other day or
anybody that acts like we act like
elitists and I'm like we're the most
did somebody really say we're elitist
well I mean in general whenever the oh
you [__] about people not donating or
like they all like that like we're just
like we're these five like were these
[__] Network [__] on a podcast
talking about Paul buffano
dude this is this is exactly it's all
this inside baseball [__] that
nobody [__] cares about we can move
on from this we don't have to keep
listening to this because at this point
I don't even know how to make this funny
because they're so bad
they are really bad and they're bad with
writers so I hope they crank out a lot
of episodes of this I hope this becomes
like talking Sopranos
that would I hope the writers never come
back yeah I 100 agree I hope the writers
never come back I hope they die yeah me
too me too you don't deserve happiness
it just makes me like it makes me laugh
whatever like what about the writer's
strike I'm like these people need to get
back to work they need to feed their
families I'm like I want them these
people want me dead I want them all
physically dead I don't care